[拍手]
今日は来ましたです
フランは東京で会社の代表として会社経営をしているんですけど今日は一人の写真家と
してちょっとこの場に足を運びました
星の王子さまって知ってますか
フランス人の3出口ペリっていう有名な
えっと小説家が書いた本なんですけどそこにこんな言葉があります
大切なものは目に見えない
今日はこの言葉をお借りして僕が大切なものを見つけるまでの話をご皆さんにお伝えし
て皆さんが大切なものを見つけるときのヒントになればいいなと思って合わせしたなと
思ったり
先ほどご紹介にもあったんですけど僕は今
カップルとか家族とかのデータに同行して写真を撮るというサービスを意味しています
そんな僕がえっカメラに出会ったのは大学1年生の頃です
高校生までは本当にこう趣味とか特急とかあんまりなくて本当にこうぼんやり
大学に入ったらこう良い友達作っていい思い出作ってなんとなくいい感じで働きたい
なぁみたいことを思いやりを持っていました
でいざー実際大学に入ってみていろんなサークルに所属したりだとか
いろんな合宿に参加者だとかいろいろしたんですけど今市子面白くなかった
イマイチ面白くなくてこのまま他の大学生活が4年間終わるのかなみたいなことを
ぼんやり思っているときに友人から
ミスコン運営している学生団体に所属しないかと
追分いただきました
そこでは学生団体なんでこうサークルで経験できないことができるよって言われたんで
なら別に今特にこれがしたいっていうものはなかったんですけどなまあなんかちょっと
行ってみようかなと思って初めて参加した会議で先輩にカメラ好きな人がいたんですの
人にカメラ楽しいよって教えてもらったのがきっかけでカメラを始めたみたいな感じ
です
なぜか思ったからカメラが好きで今こんな感じにたるって言うのではなくて本当にこう
たまたま入ったサークルでたまたま入った学生団体でたまたまカメラのでやったという
感じです
もともと趣味のなかった僕にとってカメラのある生活っていうのは本当に楽しくて
今までは功徳に行く趣味とかもなかったのでこんなにか自分の誇れるものだ前なかった
んですけど
カメラを始めてからは自分の大学の友達は取ったりだとか
先輩について写真あつったりだとか
をしていく中でどんどんいろんな人からなんかをカメラといったらこのしたとか
このしたと言ったらカメラ下手な感じでいろんな人から内角を呼ばれるようになりまし
た
なんで僕からすると
カメラはやっぱできた ih だったんですよね
えっ
でそこから煌1年間ずーっとこういうようなところ写真を撮るかどうしてきて最後
北1ミスコンの運営団体に参加してたのでそこでこうミスこのファイナルのイベント
まあ候補者の最後の一を決めるみたらイベントがあったんですけどそこでこう
イベント自身をすごく成功していろんな人がこうお客さんも泣いてるし
この候補者の人もらえてるしまた運営
明日も一年間頑張っていてたのですごくも涙を流してるみたいな感じだったんですけど
なぜか僕だけ泣けなかったんですよ
でっ
何で負けなかったんだろうって考えたときに僕ずっと自分のために写真を撮ってた
なーって思ったんですよね
最初はその友達をとって喜んでもらうことが嬉しかったはずなのにいつのまにかく
いろんな人に褒められるようになってもっと試行を褒められたりとかもっと sns で
評価されたいみたいなもしおいしいね頑張ってたんですけどある程度そのイベントが
終わった頃って周りからの評価もあったし
oss の評価もあったんですけど全く達成感を感じなかったみたいな
封筒じゃあその服ってせ自分のために頑張れるタイプじゃなくて誰かのために頑張る
タイプなんだなぁと思ってその原点は
写真を通して人を幸せにしたいみたいな事を持ってえっとその学生団体を卒業しました
もともと僕社会学部に所属していたので
マスコミとかジャーナリズムみたいなことは日頃から勉強していていわゆるその真実を
伝えたいみたいな気持ちが結構強かったんですよね
そんなことを思っているときに実は最初戦場カメラマンになろうかなと思ったんですよ
ね
戦場カメラマンになって世界から戦争をなくしたいなとか
世界の悲惨な現状を伝えることでもっと戦争がなくなればいいなと思ってたんですけど
ただ実際戦場カメラマンになってセンチの写真を撮ったとしてもその人の気持ちは
変えることができても人の行動を変えることができないよねって思ったんですよねこれ
は具体的にどういうことかっていうとたとえばその線
その写真を見て悲しい気持ちにさせることができたとしてもじゃあ明日から戦争と目に
行こうってその写真を見た人の行動を変えることができるかといったらなかなか難しい
よねって思いました
じゃあその戦場カメラマンで世界平和にするみたいな事は難しいんだったじゃあどう
やったら世界中の人を幸せにできるだろうみたいなことを考えた時に僕はこう思いまし
た
幸せというのは大きさじゃなくて風が大事なんだ
大きな幸せって例えば何かというとなんかお金持ちになるとか演出とか
例えばそういう大きな幸せがこう数年に1回あるよりも毎日幸せと思えた方が絶対人と
豊かなよねって思ったんですよね
例えば友達がいることに気付いてもらうとパートナーがいることに気付いてもらうとか
例えばその家族いることに気付いてもらうみたいな感じでその
幸せに気付いてもらう必要があるなと思ったんですよね
やっぱり幸せになるのってすっごく難しいんですよね
酸っぱく難しくてやっぱり人間って幸せになりたいと思った時に何を考えるかというと
今持ってないものを得たいと思うんですよねあの人はこんなに良いものを持ってるね僕
は持ってないとか
あの人はこんなに恵まれてない自分は恵まれてないみたいな感じで
もっとにものばかり数えてしまうんですよね
でもその持ってないものばかり数えたらずっとどんな鍵何かを得たとしてもずっとその
渇きは彼は彼は息が潤うことはないなって思ったんですよね
だったらその今ないものに目を向けるんじゃなくて今目の前にある幸せ
恋人がいるとかパートナーがいるとか科学いるみたいなそういう意味今目の前にある
幸せっていうのを写真を撮ってあげることで気づいてもらうことができたらその人の
人生を豊かにできたんじゃないかなその人の幸せを作れたんじゃないかなって思うよう
になりました
ねその幸せという切り口で撮影された写真を見てその写真を見た人たちもと温かい
気持ちになってその人たちがまたで刺した
終わった周りの人に振る舞うことができたら結果その優しさの連鎖は世界を救うんじゃ
ないかなと思いました
えっ
そこでたどり着いたテーマが
love です
初めは本当に身近だったカップルが撮影したんですけど今はそのカップルから夫婦を
取るようになったりだとか家族を撮るようになったりだとか
最初のカメラマンも全然なかったんですけどいまでは日本全国に150名を超える
思いを共にしたカメラマンたちが日々愛というテーマね写真を撮り続けています
金子れ早いもので僕が初めてカップを撮影した日からもう4年くらい経つんですけど
そう逆からずっと撮影しているお客さんが得ます
これが進行の時に撮った写真ですね真言突破気に撮った写真でその次にどんな写真を
撮ったかというと
次は子供を妊娠しましたと妊娠したでまず沿ってくださいって言って写真撮りに来まし
た
その次どんなときに撮ったかっていうと次は子供が生まれましたと
生まれたんでその時にとってほしいたその次に取ったのが
またこの
その子が歩くようになったと歩くになったからまたとってほしいと
で最後際一番最近撮った写真なんですけどこれが子どもが離せなと話せになったのはた
写真を撮ってほしいと
でこのカップルを取り続けて僕はその写真を撮り続けることの本当の価値っていうのに
気づきました
今の世の中ってどんどんどんどん色んなもの勝ちがなくなってってると思うんですよね
例えばスマホとかって毎年毎年新しいものが出て今持ってるスマホとかって来年にゃん
も価値が下がってたりだとか
例えば人工知能みたいなものが流行っていくとどんどん今ある仕事とかってなくなって
いくわけですよね
なんでこれから出なかってどんどんどんどん時間がたてばたつにつれて価値がなくなっ
ていくものばっかりなんですけど
ただ唯一時間がたてばたつにつれて価値が上がっていくものが僕は思い出だと思ってる
んですよね
思い出っていうのは今日撮った写真を明日見返すよりも京都と写真を10人組かした
ほうがずっと価値になってるよねみたいな
ということで
思い出っていうものをどんどん形にしてことによってこの世界
世界中の愛を形にすることによって世界中の人をお知らせしていきたいなと思っており
ます
改めて冒頭にお話ししたその
大切なものを目に見えないっていうところなんですけど
やっぱりその大切なものっていうのは
見えないと言うんですけど目に見えるものって
に嘔吐しなくても見えるんですよね
ただ目に見えない物って見ようとしないと見えないんですよね
これをみんなにを忘れてほしくないなと思っていてえっ
写真の世界でもこんな話が羽化があるんですけど
腕のいい写真家は余白の使い方が上手いみたいな話があるんですよね
それって単純にその被写体の周りにあるその余白スペースの話の余白とかいう意味では
なくてすべてを伝えないっていう意味での余白
なんですよね
例えばいい写真で後ときってそのそこに写っている人の声が聞こえてきたりだとか
例えばその写真に写ってる前後のストーリー本舗が映ってないんだけれども
前後のストーリーみたいなものが見えてきたりとかするんですよねそこがいわゆる写真
の奥深さだと思っていて
写真っていうのは何を映すかっていうのが大事なのじゃなくて
何を映さないかっていうのが大事なんですよねで腕のいい写真家ほどその本当に大切な
ものをあえて打つさんに見てるって想像させるんですよね
でその見えないものを見る力っていうのはぜひなんかみんなにも付けて欲しいなと思っ
ていて
今日はこの話をぜひしたいなと思っています
例えば好きなことを仕事にしたいって思ったが切って例えばそうですね何か写真でも
いいですよ
例えば写真が好きってなった時に写真にかかわる仕事がしたいってなっちゃうんですよ
ね
本当に大事なのってそこじゃなくてそのなんで写真が好きなのかって考えほしいですよ
ね例えば
なんで写真が好きっていう理由は人それぞれでよくて
例えば何かを表現するのが好きとか人と関わるのが好きか
例えば人を笑顔にするのが好き人に喜んでもらうのがスキッと月限は何でもいいんです
けど
なんでっていうことを考えることによっていままで
写真に関わる仕事がしたいとしか考えてなかった思考が1個深くなって人に喜んで
もらえる仕事がしたいみたいな
今まで見えなかったもん
が見えてくるんですよねそうなってくると何が起こるかというと今まで写真っていう
くくりでずっとお仕事を探していたりた方が選択肢を探していたんですけど
1個深くなった人に喜んでもらうということを
選択しぬ基準にその選択肢を選べるになると何で自分の選択肢がぐっと広がるよねって
いう話が今日できたなと思っております
もともと僕自身もよく言われるんですけど
もともとカメラマンになりたかった人が今会社の経営者みたいな事やってて新なくなっ
たりしないんですかって言われるんですけどもうその答えはノーですと
いやもうちょっと楽しいですという話をよくしているんですけどそれは何でかって言う
と僕はもともとそのか
写真が撮りたくてそのカップの写真を取り出したわけではないんですよね
人を幸せにしたいっていう目的を達成するためにカップの写真を撮ったという
ただ今は自分ひとりで写真を撮ることよりもより思いに共感した多くのカメラマンたち
を巻き込んでより多くの幸せを見出すことが結局僕なりたいことなんです
結局日にやるよその手段の部分は変わったんですけど
やろうとしていることなそうとしてことは全く変わってないよねっていうことなんです
よね
ぜひみなさんにもやっぱりこの目に見えないものを大切にするとかっていう感覚は
すごくつかんでほしいなと思っていて
これからどんどん大人になっていくとやっぱり校目に見えるものに囚われちゃうんです
よね
お金とか肩書きとかステータスとかっていうものにどんどん取られちゃうんですけど
本当に大事なものっていうのはそういうところになくて
目に見えないところにあるんですよねそれってもしかしたら人の思い出っていうものか
もしれないし人の気持ちっていうところかもしれないし
これから描く人の未来なのかもしれないし見えないところに行くそう大切なものがある
んですよね
300しゃべりは大切なものは目に見えないと言ったんですけど僕は好意変えたいなと
思っています
目に見えないものこそ大切なんですよね
今日この話を聞いて少しでも多くの人がこう
人生が幸幸せになることを心から願っています
視聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]